ava said she kept the underwear so where
are they in your home
i would have to ask her i don't you know
i don't i don't speak for eva mendes and
i said
can i please have that underwear
please i never asked for anything so
anyway i do have it i'm wearing it right
now
oh okay
i just
there was something about the image that
sparked like my you know that little
teenage yep that's it
ten year anniversary this year a place
beyond the pines fond memories of that
movie of course very soft spot in my
heart
just very yeah that's a special movie to
me
lloyd
i got an urgent locate and destroy
that could be fun the man's got some
street cred miss witter just said the
nicest thing about you
she just said this man
he is someone who defends women he sides
with women he looks out for women and
that you did it in every moment on set
where does that come from what's what's
in you i don't know if it's your your
lovely of course family or whatever it
is but where where does that come from
and you because she was complimenting
the heck out of you
my mom
well tonight
we are here uh with this awesome cast
but i have to tell you something the
russo brothers told me they said that
they thought that you and chris were
maybe a little intimidated by reggae
jean page your response
he's very cool
he's very cool you look cool who are you
wearing tonight
uh
oh just this little designer i found
called gucci
yeah it's a good time you checked them
out
they're pretty cool i was also talking
to julia she said you were so wonderful
to her on set that you
shared with her about being a child
actor that you taught her a lot um what
was it like to kind of be her protector
on this set because that's very much
your character's role
she had a great team of people around
her and she did a great job you know i
think uh you know
she's a filmmaker too you know when we
when the the russo's first introduced me
to her when we first all met she was
showing the films that she was making
uh you know so uh you know
she came at it from a filmmaker's
perspective
[Music]